so let's get started street kid nomad
or corpo which will you pick first
[Music]
well who do we have here
grew up in haywood whole street was my
family
neighbors helped each other out thought
nothing of it
i'm pleased to see you have enough
without dudes
born here live here die here
childhood memories hopping buildings
running away from badges iron taste of
blood from a split lip
got [ __ ] fighting for a slice of
the street get the [ __ ] out of vista
keep getting jumped and find some
stronger tubers
do you want to spend the rest of your
days blasting scabs
or become a legend overnight
we have a ride
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
my childhood let's see
racing my bobber for the first time
through the hills
oh and uh first kiss in the middle of a
synth cornfield
we nomads choose who to make our family
a choice forges strong bonds and a
higher duty that stands solid as an old
oak
[Music]
my family's in pieces that's why i'm
headed for night city
makes you an outcast among outcasts
miss this you know camaraderie
i know i saw it in your heart the first
time you met
you know what i always liked about
nomads your taste
no hunger for freedom not easy to come
by in that city
corpse got their grubby claws and
everything
i have those reports you asked for they
were supposed to be ready yesterday
the world's going to tear us apart when
the word gets around
the world's never going to find out
if i go down you're going down with me
no i'm not [ __ ] joking this isn't a
request
v but no way you're [ __ ] right
you're the one who fixes other people's
[ __ ] if you work in our soccer counter
intel
you're always [ __ ] today
they got you to zero somebody
tomorrow i'll get somebody else to zero
you
what's the rules jack want to be top
got to have some skin in the game yeah
but you're not on top
live for yourself that's the only way
philip it is so good to see you again
it's actually been a while since i've
had a chance to interview you about
cyberpunk
so i think for today we'll start with a
question that everybody wants to know
how does the path you pick affect your
time in night city
it actually affects your time quite a
lot throughout the whole game but let's
start at the beginning because basically
our game
has three different starts depending on
your life path
as an example if you choose the street
kid life path you have lived most of
your time in night city
you know the streets you know the gangs
you know the slang you kind of know
what's going on
in the let's say lower life aspects of
the city
which can of course give you lots of
good opportunities also later on in the
game
but if you start as a nomad you actually
used to be part of a nomad clan
and a nomad family because nomads that
roam the deserts around night city
that we call the badlands actually value
their family above anything
but for one reason or another you
actually left that family behind
and now the beginning of the game for
you will actually be
how to get into night city and how to
make a new life there
then you can also choose to actually be
a corporal and choose the corporate life
path
and that basically means that you're not
at home in the streets of night city
or in the deserts of the badlands but
actually inside the boardroom
because you roast the corporate letter
of the arasaka corporation
which basically gives you the ability to
sometimes you know read between the
lines
read people when they're trying to do
business which of course can give you
many nice opportunities later on
so this isn't just about the start of
the game can you maybe
help people understand how this
translates into the gameplay
yeah so the thing is we make cyberpunk a
real rpg and part of that is
that you can play your character from
the start
to the end and of course you know we
have these life paths affecting the
beginning of the game
but we wanted to make it so you have
your life path
opportunities throughout the whole game
until the
game is over and as an example we do
that by giving you
additional options and dialogues so i
can give you
one specific example and this is a
mission
where you have to steal a flathead robot
from the maelstrom gang
basically those maelstromers stole that
flathead before
from a corporate transport and the owner
of that corporate
transport merit the stout wants you to
do something else and this is an
optional objective
and even within that objective we want
to give you some options so as an
example if you have a corporate life
path
you basically know what meredith stout
is really about
you can read between the lines and you
can get some additional options that
maybe actually later enable you to do a
completely different thing with the
maelstrom gang
and if you're a nomad you know exactly
some more details about how these
maelstroms would have even been able to
steal a robot like that
from meredith stout who's part of the
very powerful militech corporation
as a street kid we as an example don't
give you a specific
new dialogue option in that dialogue
because as a street kid
you do not have a lot of experience
dealing with higher up people like
meredith stout
but we want to give you additional
options that fit your life path very
well
so later when you actually talk to the
maelstrom gang one member of the gang
offers you some illegal substance but as
a street kid you actually know what this
is about you can talk some shop with him
and that might actually make that
character like you a little bit more so
philip i do have a couple of extra
questions for you based on the video we
just saw
and the first is about nomads so the
nomad life path
this starts in a place called the
badlands is this somewhere you get to
visit
even if you don't pick nomad to start
with yes absolutely so the thing is
night city is surrounded by this huge
landscape
that we call the badlands and you can go
there whenever you want so as an example
if you actually do play the nomad life
path at the start and you are in the
badlands
you can even see night city on the
horizon and
we want to give you the option later in
the game if you want you can just take
your car
and drive out of the city you can go
there whenever you want
thing is you might not want to because
the badlands can be a pretty dangerous
place at first
because time has not been very kind to
the badlands
there have been many wars in the past
there's global warming
so most people that do live out there
don't really have another choice about
it
or are nomads that love this life and
are all about it and are very battle
hardened
we of course also want to tell their
stories because we want to tell
many many different stories throughout
the cyberpunk genre
which means that you will also find
missions that lead you out in the
badlands
or where you deal with the people living
there so philip can you tell us a little
bit more about the character padre
he's the guy we see giving his business
card to street kid v
in the video who is this man yeah so
potter is actually one of the fixers in
night city
and fixers are people that work as
intermediaries
so if someone who has a lot of money
needs a problem solved they go to a
fixer
and a fixer then finds people who can
solve that problem and these people are
people like you
the cyberpunks fixers are very
territorial
so padres specifically works from
haywood which is where you as a street
kid grew up in
so you already know him you might have
already seen another one of our fixers
who is called dexter desean
and he works in a different part of the
city so specifically padre you might
know him as a street kid
but even if you played other life paths
you might sooner or later meet him
because he's operating in haywood which
is a pretty big place with many good
jobs
so if you want to make some cash there
you will sooner or later deal with padre
philip thank you so much for joining us
now on my first playthrough pretty sure
i'm gonna be picking nomad
but for those watching we would love to
know what you'll be picking so have a
think about it and send us a tweet
don't forget that later in this episode
we're going to be showing you another
new gameplay video
and have